time for ryan reynolds now uh he may be
known for doing a lot of his own stunt
work but at the age of 45
he's so good he admits his body isn't
what he used to be and he will depend on
a stunt double more often sounds like
smart things speaking with variety about
deadpool 3 ryan admits i think it's
important to do as much of the stunt
work yourself as you can but i'll step
aside when there's something that's just
too gnarly and there's a trained
professional ready to go yeah well ryan
says he loves the physicality aspect in
action movies he jokes he's not allowed
to eat advil like cereal this is good
good advice adding things start to hurt
after i turned 35 being thrown onto
cement wasn't hilarious anymore it had
been upgraded to hell yeah that sounds
about right now with fans eagerly
awaiting the release of doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness many have
speculated a big cameo with ryan making
an appearance as deadpool but despite
the rumors ryan tells variety
i'm really not in the movie i'm
promising i'm not in the movie sure ryan
sure
of course that's probably the answer he
would give even if he was in the movie
all right so what do you think my
initial reaction was like well canadians
don't lie but wow come on now listen um
i think
after everything that happened with uh
the last spider-man movie
you know
generally speaking if someone says
they're not doing something the public
isn't so quick to say oh well then
clearly they're not doing it like
speculation for marvel movies and for dc
movies for all these comic book movies
in general
always run rampant and it's part of the
fun like we talk about all the time
that's part of the fun of being a fan
sure it was like guessing and
speculating like looking for clues like
the whole deadpool thing comes from
looking at the poster and seeing that oh
the deadpool is hidden in there oh is
that where this all started that's one
of the reasons right wow
and obviously you know we're talking
about the multiverse so that means the
possibilities are endless
that being said
given that it's fun to speculate it's
also like it does kind of like ruin
things a bit like the whole spider-man
thing for me
how cool would it have been if we didn't
know if you actually didn't know like if
you actually actually didn't know if
that footage wasn't leaked that that
blue screen footage that was leaked
man if it had been like a clean surprise
whoa
true but did it take away truly from
your experience watching that movie well
it becomes something else rather than
rather than being like
a really amazing surprise it becomes a
confirmation that you were correct and
that's right hey but fans like that too
but i mean like
so i guess it's you know 50 50 depending
on the way you look at it yeah okay so
anything i'm pretty sure if you've ever
breathed near a marvel script you're
rumored to be in the movie for sure
which is true
i think though there is something about
ryan reynolds that when he says like
guys guys i'm not in it it's almost like
we're supposed to like really believe
him there's just something about him and
not to say that andrew garfield isn't
someone that you believe
because he made like a he should get an
oscar nom for his performance in the
same note all of us including myself
when i talk to him about potentially
appearing in that in that spider-man
film um but i don't know there's
something about ryan that you're like
well if he says he's not he probably
isn't but i don't know i feel like this
isn't a knock at all like when i think
about andrew garfield i think about like
complete and total sincerity okay when i
think of ryan reynolds i think he likes
to have fun and i think he likes to be a
little bit of you know cheeky a little
cheeky right so okay i like that i still
think it's 50 50. so i have a question
then would you be excited if he was in
in uh doctor strange because we were
talking about this right before the show
and you know i'm surprised we haven't
heard of another deadpool movie in the
works obviously knowing the first two
were so successful
and
so i i actually said to you i was like
oh has it been kind of confirmed that
we're not going to get another
standalone deadpool and if that's the
case i would prefer to see him show up
in you know little bit parts and all
these other marvel films and i think dr
strange and deadpool going up against
each other would be jokes i think that
we've kind of learned that there's like
a never say never mentality about these
things like if michael keaton can come
back to be batman
in the flash and play him again moving
forward
um if we could get that snyder cut after
we all were told it didn't exist that's
true like i think all these things are
possibilities and so whenever like take
deadpool 3 as an example if there's no
confirmation a hundred percent that it's
absolutely not happening then the
possibility of it happening is exciting
enough that people will speculate on it
and
further to that if deadpool is in um
doctor strange multiverse of madness
then it sort of
heightens the possibility that we could
see him back in more stuff that's true
especially considering all like the
connections with you know professor x
potentially
potentially like we heard his voice
being in this movie like we heard him in
the trailer right
which brings in the mutants so all these
different possibilities and also where
marvel has got to go this becoming rant
where marvel has got to go further down
in bringing all different properties
back in after they've you know been
absorbed back into the disney fold um
yeah the possibilities are all there i
would love to see that so well studios
is saying would love to see deadpool in
doctor strange but also
uh is are you writing tom cruise's tony
stark iron man
this
has been a rumor is this a rumor i'm
sorry i didn't know that remember tony's
so tom cruise was originally considered
for tony stark when they were first
going to make iron man ages and ages it
just never happened and so i don't know
who started it i don't know who said
well what about this and it could very
well have been someone being like well
what about this yeah but it just kind of
picked up steam
and so now that's the thing that people
are going well maybe what
i'm all about that and crystal's saying
yeah sass and cheek is kind of ryan
reynolds
really quick to his thing about you know
um saying he will be depending on his
stunt performers more and all that um
actors get a lot of praise for doing
their stunts yes doing their fight
scenes and it's very tough work very
intricate work and very precise work but
you got to give big ups to the stunt
teams that allow them to be able to do
that that train them to be able to do
that and and the people that do put on
the suit in lieu of the actor and take
that big hit because that's real work
it's take the hit and then don't really
get the
the no
no not claimer what do you call it like
they don't get the acclaim they don't
get the attention right it's not that
necessary
that's what they're in it for no it's
true but yeah they do the work hurts yes
it does and like you know give them
credit yeah i like that